oh my God is that what that means yes
they were like you know
girls who are like choose me pick me
choose me and I'm like do you uh hello
do you know who invented girl so pick me
choose me
love me listen I I don't know if you
remember that I fought that speech so
hard yes that's another like really
interesting thing about life is
some things that I was like so against I
can't beg a man on TV this is so
embarrassing so hard right and then it
turns out to be like one of the most
successful scenes or the most favorite
it was beautiful Ellen Pompeo spilling
that behind the scenes t on one of
Gray's anatomy's most iconic lines so
pick me
choose me
love me she made the confession on
varieties actors on actors where she
also revealed how soon fans could see Dr
Meredith gray back on TV's most watched
medical drama I will be making some
appearances hopefully next year
um
no it's not a complete it's not a
complete goodbye
um and I and I think we've got an
interesting story to tell Ellen's
spectacular and I think she deserves a
little bit of creative time that's
different from what she's been doing
she's been doing this job I mean nobody
expected the show to go this many
seasons we're entering the 20th season
so she deserves the break so if she
wants to come back she comes back
you spent your entire adult life in one
place and that makes it hard to leave I
think it's okay for Meredith to
stop making bad decisions somehow
Meredith can't figure out how to make a
relationship work still after all this
time felt so happy to be able to step
away yeah and felt like I accomplished
something incredible I don't want to
abandon them Ellen sat down for a
one-on-one with her former Gray's
co-star Catherine Heigl for reunion 13
years in the making this time 13 years
ago and it just brings back so many
incredible memories it's the first time
the two actresses have spoken publicly
about Catherine's controversial exit
from the hit show
the success of Grace hit and I felt I
think it was borrowed confidence I was
so naive I got on my soapbox and I had
some things to say and I felt really
passionate about this stuff seriously
seriously
seriously there were certain boundaries
and things that I was not okay with
being crossed if you cannot stand up for
yourself in this industry
very few people will stand up for you
Catherine came under Fire after she
bowed out of the Emmy contention in 2008
at the time the actress cited a lack of
character development in what she called
unfair onset working conditions as her
reasoning behind the move our first day
back was Wednesday and it was I'm going
to keep saying this because I hope It
embarrasses them a 17-hour day really I
think is cruel and mean nobody likes a
competent woman because that makes them
nervous Catherine later asked to be let
out of her contract in early 2010 to
pursue a film career
to fight and you have to be brave and if
it all goes away because you fought and
you were Brave then it all goes away you
were just a little early
because they came out with this thing
where everybody's got their own box and
their own megaphone and they get a blue
check yeah it's called Twitter
[Music]